hey guys it is Tuesday the twentieth of
January today my name is Jess McDonald
and be sure that you're watching is
called against but news thanks for
checking it out if you've got yourself a
Playstation you may have noticed it's
only suffering a bit of PSN downtime
over the Christmas period thanks to a
DDoS attack Sony feels super bad that
you had to spend time with your families
instead of escaping to the wide world of
online video games so they're offering a
one-time 10% playstation store discount
if you make a purchase in the store
through your ps3 ps4 or online the
discount only runs for 4 days starting
January 23 so you'll have to get in
quick Sony is providing the discount
code on the PlayStation Store and via
their Twitter account they're also
extending existing PS plus subscriptions
by five days at no extra cost if you
came to play state of decay on your xbox
one you can now drop the release date of
April twenty-eighth down on your
calendar the year one survival edition
is going to run at 1080p which is higher
than the current xbox 360 version which
currently runs at 720 this expanded
edition of the open-world zombie
survival game is also coming to PC
microsoft also had a couple of
additional release dates to announce
today including one for roller coaster
games scream ride developed by the
creators of roller coaster tycoon which
will come out on march three and
adventure platformer Orion the blind
forest will launch much 11 finally
Borderlands 2 and the pre-sequel are
going to make their way to xbox one and
ps4 in the newly announced handsome
collection the collection includes
Borderlands 2 the pre-sequel and all the
DLC that's ever been you can get your
hands on it come up 24 if you live in
North America you'll be able to carry
save files over from the xbox 360 and
ps3 so no worries about losing your
progress and there is cross save
functionality so long as consoles are
within the same family the handsome
collection also offers up a split screen
option for up to four players if you're
really
into this one you can get one of the
five thousand claptrap in a box editions
which include the handsome collection a
steel case 12 lithographs and a remote
controlled claptrap unit which should be
done but surprisingly looks really
freaking awesome let me know down in the
comments if you're more keen to play
remastered Borderlands 2 or remark this
state of decay geez someone really needs
to make them new video games for more
news you can hedge against part where
we've got stories on old Star Wars games
you can play on God and Club Nintendo
shutting down that is all the good stuff
I want to tell you about today let me
know what you cared about and I will
catch you tomorrow